always and i always learn a lot
all right so i will present here what
we've been doing uh in my lab
now at barcelona supercomputing center
over the past three years or so
i'm still in london as well although not
so much and i just found it a startup
called graphic technologies and i will
talk about what components
we are using for it
so just to motivate we've seen many of
you talk about different kinds of own
data
we're just
learning more and more about less and
less we have all sorts of these things
that you guys talked about
but also the foodon the allerg or
whatever it's pronounced and all other
ohms
so uh all of these data basically uh
consist of molecular entities or not
even molecular entities super molecular
entities or cells or tissues or organs
or even
entire humans so uh they can be
represented as nodes in networks and
then if there is some interaction or
relationship or correlation between them
then an edge
so we have various kinds of let's say
molecular networks um
that measure different things in a cell
we also have various networks where
drugs could be uh molecules and then for
instance they're chemical similarities
it could be edges or if they cause the
same side effects it could be an edge or
whatever then we have various kinds of
ontologies so the
uh
we are all looking for the same thing
how much information can we or knowledge
can we extract
out of these data types sometimes in
isolation from others which is very
important but also what we care about in
my lab is how to integrate them or fuse
them together to see what collectively
they tell us and how to put that in a
patient-centric
way and
we design
new methods new algorithms how to do
this
because basically of the underlying
computational interact-ability of many
problems that deal with these large
networks or graphs
so that's kind of in a nutshell and now
i will present just some illustrations
of the methodologies that we've been
developing a couple of you have seen
some of these the first part of this uh
previously because it's from a paper
from 2019
but others asked me to talk about it
because it's not only the result of my
erc consolidator grant that's still
ongoing but also uh the main thing in
the in my rsd proof of concept brand
with which we founded graphic
technologies
so
this paper is about
different
types of omix data we make them tissue
specific for particular cancers and the
control or proxies for healthy
cells then we fuse them into this new
model that we call an eye cell or an
integrated cell
so this is just another network this is
a new model of biology and then we
compare them we compare them using
graphites many of you heard me talk
about it for the past 15 years or so
and then by this comparison we get new
cancer genes and we got phenotypic
validations so let me slowly uh
lead us through through this uh paper
now these different kinds of umix data
that we collect about the cell they are
uh qualitatively different they measure
different things this is like putting
different pair of glasses onto look at
the same thing at the cell
and this is why when we look at the
overlap in terms of the number of genes
in the protein protein interaction
genetic interaction and coexpression we
we have
3 000 roughly genes in the overlap but
only one shared interaction and these
are the the data bases that we that we
use for this and this is collectively
for all of them and there is no mistake
here it's just they measure different
things
and because of uh
almost no overlap here this is why most
of the other data integration or fusion
methods fail and when i say data
integration or fusion i don't mean
amalgamation of the data putting them on
the top of each like everything together
in a database what i mean in in terms of
modeling in terms of mathematics so
these are some of those that fail and
they fail for various reasons
maybe they don't converge
or
produce very large number of very small
clusters et cetera et cetera they all
have different problems and this is why
we needed to come up with the new method
and this is how we went about it so we
created these tissue-specific networks
we get tissue specific gene expression
from the human protein atlas but keep in
mind that this is not a microarray or
rna-seq this is antibody staining blow
throughput data low number of samples
they don't represent all patients just a
small number of them so later on if you
don't see your favorite gene that you
love
uh then it's it was just not in the data
there's nothing wrong with the method
right
um and then basically you overlay this
on the top of these generic protein
interaction networks
data from
coexpress db or genetic interactions
these are static interactions to get
these tissue specific
interaction networks and also we only
consider genes with expression available
in the human protein atlas and at least
two actually protein protein
interactions so that these methods would
work
um so this is what i said so nodes are
genes expressed in the tissue from the
human protein atlas whether it's cancer
or control and they're linked by
interactions and we took at first the
four most prominent cancers in human
um and uh control uh tissues of origin
so breast prostate lung color rectal
and then this is just to show you that
when we make these tissue specific
networks both for control and cancer
they're pretty large data sets you have
on the order of ten thousand nodes
uh tens or hundreds of thousands of
interactions so basically you can use
methods such as this one
now this eye cell prototype works as
follows and this is actually
conceptually very simple
so you have these uh so protein
interaction network expression and
genetic interaction network
so each one of them is genes to genes
right in these matrices a1 a2 and a3
they all color coded
and then what you do is you approximate
each one of them
simultaneously as a product of three
lower dimensional matrix factors
where you share this one corresponding
to genes these are genes here and this
is some low dimension dimensionality
much lower than the number of g's let's
say
let's say it's not 50 but let's say
right
and then so basically this is the same
corresponding to basically embeddings of
genes the lower dimensional space that
patrick
alluded to this morning earlier and then
these are specific to basically these
are
encapsulated representations of these
data so how do you do this you
minimize this objective function
basically and then this converges to a
local minimum and then from this matrix
factor g you multiplied by its g
transpose and then you get another g
the genes times g's
network and this is our i cell this is
the integrated cell
and this is just an illustration of this
i cell where we colored the genes by
their functional uh annotation and you
see that in in terms of reactant
pathways check pathways or biological
process you have this just visually to
see that that is functionally coherent
but not only that actually additional
functional information emerges from the
fusion of all the data despite of
basically no network overlap so how do
you see this when you clusters make
clusters i mean this is k-means
equivalent i mean you guys certainly
know about that so then and when you uh
in these clusters of genes see how many
genes are enriched in this place let's
say in reactant pathways and again
color-coded pink is for eye cell and the
other colors are for here in the
data actual data for which we made the i
cell you see that in eye cell it's much
higher in which functional enrichment so
this is the new functional information
that emerges from this mathematics from
this fusion from this new model and then
you can test the contribution so this is
highly modular i'll show you in another
example
so if you include all data then
basically you get the highest
enrichments for instance here in go
biological uh process annotations in
these clusters of genes now
let's uh go further
so
we have these uh tissue-specific
networks
for cancer and control these particular
ones
so the three data types that i mentioned
ppi uh
genetic interactions called expression
but also their eye cells this is a new
cell this is the new um not cell this is
the new network
now in the human protein atlas a gene is
either expressed or not in the tissue so
we find between cancer and control genes
that are cancer silence cancer activated
always silence and always express now
this always expressed maybe at different
levels let's
revisit differential expression later
but what we find for now is only these
always expressed genes are enriched in
drivers so not cancer silence not cancer
activated but always expressed which is
kind of interesting this is why then we
wanted to test the rewiring in cancer
compared to control of these always
expressed genes and they're involved in
cancer so in cancer and control i sell
network ppi network gi network and q
expression network you find the most
rewired ones and now in terms of these
graphics and i'll just put one slide
about these graphics because these were
results mostly of my previous crc
starting grant that finished oops this
is a typo here it finished in uh 2018
basically uh and
uh as soon as
after that basically i just started the
consolidator that's online
so they're still the best performing and
most robust uh it's it's a lively
research area if you put graphite in
google scholar you'll get about 21 000
results and graphics are mentioned in
about 300 patents
and they're used in many machine
learning algorithms they're generalized
to work with directed network with
probability the probabilities on the
edges on hyper graphs
basically that model multi-scale
organization data such as protein
complexes and pathways we generalize
laplacians to graph little laplacians to
take care of the expanded neighborhoods
not just direct neighbors then we
generalize the spectral embedding and
clustering as well uh
we we just published i think this year
graphic diagram centralities etc etc and
we apply all that to biology but others
apply that to social sciences et cetera
this is uh even image processing
uh it's it's a big research area okay
back from graphites now we find the most
rewired genes in cancer versus control
in the eye cell network ppigi and cox
network in each of them individually and
only in eye cells rewiring is indicative
of involvement in cancer and the top 500
most rewired are in enriched in
dry in cancer drivers and cancer-related
pathways
so not in any of these rewiring you know
in ppi gi cox no only in eye cell
okay
so now to test this further whether it
makes any biological sense we talk we
took top 20 of the most wired
in cancer eye cells only because in eye
cells this works for the four cancers so
when you add
you know four times 20 it's 80 but some
of them repeated so there is 63 unique
and we validated almost all of them
either through literature
or we did our own knockdown experiments
followed by cell viabilities so you can
see for instance if these genes
mediations of these genes in this cell
line results in significantly
significantly reduced cell viability in
cancer and for instance in this cell and
line
mutations of these insignificantly
increased cell viability in cancer
now
also we
went into survival validate the others
through retrospective analysis of
patient survivals
and this is what i uh said i will say
later these differential expressions out
of these 63
only 17 so 27 are differentially
expressed in cancer so the differential
expression that we've heard about
yesterday and today tells you something
but it's not the full picture so each of
the data types tells you something but
it's not the full picture and you have
to come up with these mathematical
models to extract more out of all of
these data collectively so this is
how do you define rewiring
in terms of these graphlets and i just
put one slide so basically
uh it's a methodology that we published
a long time ago
2007 of tccd conference and you were
in
in
there some of you were there
uh so basically you
uh take a look at the extended
neighborhoods around the north maybe
you've heard of network motifs this is
kind of like networking so a very very
important technical difference so
basically looking like at these numbers
of triangles squares paths and stuff
around one or the other and you know how
different they are in a nutshell so you
have these feature vectors counting
these and then you compare these feature
vectors based on the counts of these
small substructures
this is when you're demanding a certain
level of change in these motifs yeah
yeah yeah yeah very very big yeah very
big change in that exactly exactly
why we had that i was wondering
something similar when you say there was
no rewiring in the protein interaction
data
those are most of the time you know
reference maps that were collected in
the single conditions so how did you
assess
you know what was your
measure is the most rewired ones right
so we took the most required ones in
terms of graphics right which data did
you put in there
yeah but for the protein protein
interaction data from an i2d database
from uh igor where you reach its as
database from toronto he was my phd
advisor so right a big one only
experimenting with validated data that's
the data in particular sorry for protein
from interactions that we use here so we
found the most rewired in each one of
these okay checked in them enrichment in
drivers and only in i sells they these
top 500 most rewards were enriched in
drivers i i understand that but i'm
sorry for for doing
[Music]
for the protein interaction that's very
little cancer specific data right
so so how do you yeah yeah i think uh
patrick asked me that when we were at
the conference site you organized at uh
long island called spring harbor so and
i explained that of course we have to go
a few slides before
so it's here how do i make them so
basically i take from the human hair
from the human protein atlas these
specific cancer-specific expression data
and tissue control and also in i2d this
is this pro contraction database at
least two ppis and then basically you
overlay
these on the top of this everybody does
it the same way so this is how you get
the
tissue specific
interactions of whatever type whether
it's ppi or geography
but we can talk about it if you're
confused at the moment
yes so
where were we
uh
yes so
right i think we were here then we went
penn cancer so once we found this for
four cancers
then we added everything that was
available at the time at tcga so 20 in
total so these are the cancers we made
their eye cells and we're asking now
whether similarly why are genes in
different cancer eye cells are cancer
related
we found just over 3000 genes
expressed in all
cancer types and then we found the most
wiring similar out of them in these
cancer eye cells and then the top 500
were significantly enriched in drivers
again right
and then basically uh we found so these
are the our top ranked ones based on
this and for instance so basically we
validated all of them nearly
but this one for instance uh
we could not find any evidence but then
we went to human protein atlas we found
that it significantly
impacts patient survival in eight
different cancer types and this is for
pancreatic this picture
all right so
okay
right so basically this is about the eye
cell so differential expression or any
other type of data carries limited
information and we can expand more if
you fuse the data this is also very
generic and then let me show you so this
was the first example for cancer this
eye cell paper and let me show this is
unpublished work we're just writing it
up so this is about rare form of form of
thrombophilia
and with rare diseases you have very few
uh genomes of these people in this
particular case we had the somatic
mutation
of only two families two brothers one
diseased one healthy and the daughter of
the healthy brother that was diseased
who was diseased and then we had two
sisters another family
um so here are the genes and these
expressions were not expression these
different kinds of molecular interaction
networks that we've seen in the eye cell
so this is your eye cell but here we
kind of shyly at this one additional
data type these are your patients these
five guys and then germ limitations so
here by fusing this data in this simple
way basically you boost the signal so
because you don't have statistical power
from from the the so few uh uh
people uh then if you add these
molecular interaction networks the thing
is that uh
there is a super exponential number of
the ways this can be rewired so you
boost the signal by the state diffusion
and you can find things out for instance
this is a cluster of genes the molecular
networks that are
characteristic to all diseased women and
this one is characteristic these mutated
genes to the healthy brother and this is
probably what protects this guy from
being deceased so
we are we are writing this up another
one uh so
let me just uh uh now go into these
different types of data so this is your
eye cell this is for instance this one
that we just saw patients two genes
let's say somatic mutation profiles but
you can add whatever you want in it for
instance you can add these drugs
and then maybe chemical similarities are
the edges between them and then you have
drug target interactions here and then
you can you have this that these drugs
were given to these patients or these
patients could receive these particular
drugs etc
and then so what we like about these
this kind of modeling is because it
captures all systems level data
unprocessed and transformed at their
full size
and also how the data relate and this is
the trick you you when if you capture
precisely how the data relate then you
have very few parameters to tune
uh in this particular machine learning
method and not only that it's
explainable so trivially you get
mechanistic explanations in the sense
let's say i repurpose that this drug
should be given to this patient and then
i ask you why well and then you say
because this patient has these two
mutated genes that these drug binds to
so this is kind of
simplified and what you're doing is then
basically these matrices across the data
types you're simultaneously
decomposing them into these lower
dimensional matrix factors by and by
sharing the factors across the
composition you're ensuring data fusion
and all within one minimization function
where you're adding prior knowledge or
penalties from where these interactions
are in the data types in your
minimization process by these here
traces of these these here are
laplacians of your interaction networks
right
so
um now uh at psb now six years ago we
published this this was uh from tcga
serous ovarian cancer patients 350 each
of them where we used this minimization
function and basically uh decompose the
somatic mutation profiles and drug
target interactions and then from this
one formula that you minimize once uh
you get patient certification from the
cluster of patients you get cancer gene
predictions from the clusters of genes
that uh are enriched in
uh cancer genes and then you get drug
repurposing from these uh drug target
interactions basically uh
matrix completion property
and uh this again illustrates how
modular it is if you only use drug
target interactions to predict drug
targeting interactions this is how
accurate you are but when you start
adding more data you're more and more
accurate
and so forth so this is five-fold
cross-validation just kind of in a
nutshell and now the last five or ten
minutes i have five
is uh so we applied this to covid very
early on we got um
the viral host interactions from the
kruger lab we also got the
differentially expressed genes in lungs
we wanted to bring the repurposing into
the human genes rather the antivirals
which are tricky
so
uh basically we took the data from these
databases this is your 30-ish viral
proteins to 300-ish human genes viral
host interactions these are human
molecular interaction networks this is
drug target
so drugs 4 000 drugs to 2000 something
human genes and then drug to drug
chemical similarities and then you
decompose at the same time viral human
matrix and
human genes to drugs
sharing this factor to ensure the fusion
and then you get co-clustering and
matrix completion for drug repurposing
once we repurpose the drugs
then we were wondering because they were
quite a number like where which ones
should we repurpose the one that hit
receptors everybody loves these drugs
that bind to receptors or where do you
heat and then we we took these uh
human viral interactors basically so
and then we took their neighbors and
then we took differentially expressed
genes like should we
differentially express genes everybody
loves differentially expressed genes
and then the neighbors of differentially
expressed genes and the neighbors of
these viral interacting proteins and it
turns out that only these common
neighbors are enriched in viral
functions and these are enrichments some
of the enrichments nothing else is
enriched differentially expressed genes
and not enriched in vinyl processes nor
these receptors etc
and these are very unique these common
neighbors as we call them
a very interesting topological part of
the network the
very central in terms of many measures
including graphlets
and then
when we saw so basically there were
around 50 genes there and targeted by
100 around 150 drugs and out of these
150 drugs around 30
already you know were either in golf
trials
database or in coordinate database so
these are validations that we predicted
quite correctly 30 percent
uh and then at the time i had a biology
postdoc who since moved to uh
industry somewhere in germany went back
home when corona hit and then uh so
basically he did some uh analysis and
basically all of these converge to vegf
and nitric oxide signaling but i don't
have the time to go into this and these
are some of these
top uh
predictors just to say that with these
methodologies we are uh
uh analyzing single cell expression data
fusing them with networks this is with
alex cooping as part of the itn project
this is marie curie project so what they
do in their lab they start from from uh
pluripotent stem cells within without a
mutation that's uh
for parkinson's important to them and
then they measure uh with the single
cell drug seek analysis uh at day zero
day six day 15 and day 21 of controls
and parkinson's disease basically they
measure this expression so this is the
number of genes that will measure the
number of single cells and then
basically we are fusing these data with
uh four different types of uh networks
three types of no one two three four
types of molecular networks
these are single cells to genes this is
expression of these genes and this is
again data fusion and we are finding
basically where and when
this change happens and how to intervene
with already known drugs what we could
perhaps repurpose
and in the end in the last two minutes
uh so basically this is one of the
papers from last year by a very talented
phd student of mine alexander zemos
so we are using the similar thing to do
gene embeddings we've seen some so
basically network embeddings we've seen
some uh that uh uh
patrick mentioned this morning
uh and basically everything that you
have seen
you know you can consider it as an
embedding but the let's say in this
particular paper protein interaction
network this is human protein
interaction network by this methodology
we're embedding in lower dimensional
space where we can control for
orthonormality so to minimize the
dependencies between these these bases
of of the space
and then basically we are seeing what's
happening in the space so in the space
the g is basically that were clusters in
the network we would like them to come
close in space and they do
and we find that the space is
functionally organized basically you
know what what comes close to space
basically these genes belong to the same
functions so just in a nutshell uh then
what is very interesting here is so you
have um for each gene you have a vector
in the space
and now you can do simple linear
operations these vectors such as you add
them and you know you have to find the
average
and that
and basically then you find the
proximity to those points with cosine
you know
and then you can predict
new members of protein complexes and
also cancer genes
and we found some uh
these are some of our predicted cancer
genes and we validated
all of that so
that's kind of that uh so just to say
that this is a very versatile machine
learning methodology
uh you can put in whatever you want like
eqtls that we listened to about just had
the talk before or
something mutation prefers expressions
methylations copy number variations
clinical profile similarity treatments
adverse effects whatever you want it's
here
however each time you pose it it's
different np card continues optimization
problems you have to propose objective
function optimization solver proof
convergence correctness and optimization
slow and this is why we are at the
supercontinuing center and we use it
extensively
so
but maybe with these embeddings we can
do better so uh now uh to conclude we
have seen the importance of precision
medicine and um
um
uh the strategic intelligence of the
work a world economic forum underline it
these artificial intelligence and data
science and multi-org science here and
etc etc it's all around there uh i hope
i convey the message that we need to
merge them all together
this is a result of my erc consolidator
grant with which we make new ai methods
and also we are commercializing it we
just founded this graphic technology
startup we are doing the normal drug
discovery uh precision drugs in silico
that is disease and target agnostic and
we are also in addition to that doing
many other tasks of precision medicine
from all formic data collectively kind
of using what you have just seen and not
to forget to train new people everybody
is going to industry these days there's
going to be nobody left in computer
science to teach the people anymore so
we published this book a couple years
ago at cambridge university press for
basically training embedding data
scientists who would like to do this
multi-disciplinary work
as a textbook for phd students and
postdocs and in the end for funding i
thank the organizations that supported
me over the years of course my group
members without none of this would be
possible this is part of my group in
barcelona
past members collaborators and learned
societies and i'd like to thank you for
your attention
yes
uh
it feels that the data may be related
repurposing effort comes with this
[Music]
and stuff but you know once your paper
is in and he's not out you cannot
compare it would be interesting but
honestly to me i mean he said does it
work or does it not work if he's meant
to find something else that works and
mind something else it's cool i mean
this is all that'd be hard i mean so
these are all approximations
so let's just find something that works
this is my approach but this is what
you're asking it's kind of more
theoretical question you know and yeah
i'm not sure
if we can
okay i think we could get an answer to
that and it would uh be about
exploring the properties of the data and
the properties of the question you're
asking and then maybe you could come up
with some general rules and we have some
ideas about that
in general
so you have to pay some attention when
you combine all these very different
data types that you can actually do in
your operations to combine them or is it
it turns out that the space is linear
and there are reasons why is linear and
which kind of data produces linearity in
the embedding space and this is why this
works
but
let me just say that and then when the
paper is published then
again
we meet again
oh